i think that uh m said he here here at
snub knows and uh two two six caught him
right so
i'm
kind of rapping fast and switching
cadences and [ __ ] and
big rubies at the beginning he's like
yeah he's like that [ __ ]
so it was snub knows it caught his
attention
cause i feel like snub nose was so like
slept on especially like on the dsps
like i feel like once you started
dropping music in the pandemic like i
was like oh [ __ ] i see i see grip on
making these [ __ ] big playlists this
is dope yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah and then people was going back to
schnub
you know i'm saying so it was cool i
think every
like every drop i've ever had like it
just kind of got bigger every time you
know what i'm saying like naturally just
it's got to be dope though like to have
like a concept project like snub knows
be the thing that catches eminem's
attention hell yeah man i felt like
cause for a long time man i was i was
kind of upset with it because like i
felt like it was it was a great body of
work that kind of just like fell under
the radar no it definitely did yeah so
then i was just like you know for a long
time i was kind of just like i was
frustrated for people who don't
understand like you had a project in
2019 you put out called snub nose this
is a project that kind of got me onto
you real tough but what like it was a
whole entire concept to the album but
break down what that was so um snub nose
of course is a is a revolver revolver
yeah so so pretty much i just like
compare like the mechanism like the
circular mechanism to like the hood like
just like our environment um so like and
kind of like spoke from the perspective
of a gun spoke on different cycles
uh
and brought it back full circle at the
end so pretty much you know in a
nutshell like that's what it was it was
like the the most creative
ill way to do what like nas and tupac
did but like over an entire body of work
the entire body of work and i just
remember like as a kid like hearing like
i gave you power oh i gave you powers
the best damn i think this is one of
those songs i was like the [ __ ] yeah i
gave you power it's like one of those
songs you're like
what the [ __ ] are we doing here i
remember like i remember like so
uh i think that it was just dope that
that at least em caught that [ __ ] you
know i'm saying like at least this kind
of catapulted me to this next level you
know what i'm saying i mean that means
that the project serves this purpose
and think about illmatic right yo matic
at the i mean was was it was a
underground favorite i mean obviously it
came out on columbia but like
really once knives really started a pop
i think a lot of people had to go back
to that go back to that [ __ ] yeah barely
just went double platinum like six
months ago you know what i'm playing
we're thinking ilmatic is just like the
holy grail the holy grail of hip-hop and
it's like bro it's barely double
platinum yeah you know what i'm saying
like i guess it'd be like reasonable
doubt same thing right without
reasonable how many people like
no [ __ ] idea about reasonable doubt
until jay started really really getting
these commercial records and yeah so i
think that's kind of like your moment